[clears throat] OpenClaw AI SEO 0 to 780
SEO traffic a day. So, OpenClaw just
became the most powerful free SEO tool
on the planet and it's getting websites
to the top of Google. Like you can see,
it's actually done with mine directly
over here. So, you can see us ranking
directly inside Google AIO overviews as
well as on the first page of Google um
using this method. You can also see for
example on our traffic that spiked up
dramatically since before and after
using AI SEO and particularly open
clause to do this. So I'm going to guide
you through the process. We're talking
about going from zero visitors to 780
clicks a day using a free AI agent that
researches topics, writes full blog
posts and publishes them to your website
on your own every single day without you
doing anything. And we're going to test
it live together right now. Here's the
problem. Google rewards websites that
publish fresh content every single day.
Writing articles is exhausting. Most
people can't do it, so their websites
never grow. OpenClaw can help you fix
that. You set up once. It does writing,
does publishing, does the research all
on autopilot. I'll show you how today.
And I'm going to show you exactly what
we did to get this article ranking on
Google like you can see. and how we went
from like literally um we were getting
like no clicks a day back over here um
to the point now where we are getting at
some days like 780 clicks a day from
SEO. Uh you can see yesterday we grew to
around about 500 or 28 clicks per day
using this method. So I'm going to guide
you through and show you how. Okay, so
here's an example. So I actually said
create an SEO optimized article for this
um use this prompt etc with open clause.
So, we're using OpenClaw inside
Telegram. If you don't know what
OpenClaw is, basically it's an AI
assistant that can go off and do things
for you. Um, and you can install it
locally. Now, you can use this same
method with any sort of um AI agent that
you want, but I just like to use Open
Claw. I can easily give it source
context. I can even give it the
tonality. I can use Claude Sonic for
writing the content and it can do a
pretty good job for me. Now if we have a
look as an example um you can see
actually created the content directly
here. Uh so this is the article that it
created for the website. And if you're
wondering okay like can it publish
directly to WordPress as well? Yes it
can. And I'll show you an example. So
for example if we go over to openclaw
here and I'll talk you through exactly
how this works. So you can see that
basically it can publish articles
directly to WordPress like this um
inside openclaw right which is pretty
insane. So it can actually for example
create content on our website just using
our keyword and we're good to go on
that. So we can see an example of the
WordPress publish page here. Also gives
us a local guide file as well. Um let's
have a look at another one. So if we
click on
the chat you can see another example. So
actually created this article directly
on Kimmy K25 and Claudebot aka Mob and
how to rank with it. Right. And the
article itself looks pretty nice. Like
look at the design, the CTA throughout
the page, even creating an image with
nano banana and then publish it to the
page as well. So let me talk you through
exactly how this works in a few separate
steps, right? So number one, what you
want to do really is you want to make
sure that when you're publishing to
WordPress inside the chat, go over to
your website. So for example, like this
and there's two things that you need.
Number one, you need a login. So you
need to get the login details for the
website. So you can just create a
separate user for openclaw. Um and I'll
talk you through how to do that in a
second. So there's so many pop-ups in
WordPress crazy. So you can see an
example of our open claw right here.
Right. So this is a separate account we
created for openclaw. And then the other
thing that you need for openclaw when
you're set up with WordPress and you
just give these login details directly
to um the AI agent is you need to get an
API token key. Right? So you get an API
token key. You can see an example right
here. So you can add an application
password and that just allows you to
connect the login details and the API
token directly to your website so that
when you put it inside the chat, it can
then create content directly using that
API. Right? So two literally two things
you need from WordPress. Number one,
login details, username, password, and
then the second one is of course the API
token. Both of those you can generate
inside WordPress. I've shown you how to
do that today. Once you've done that,
you then need a good prompt for creating
the content. Now, you can just say like
um just you can just say like create a
nice article or whatever if you want. Uh
but what I'd recommend is using a prompt
like for example, we have inside the AR
profit boardroom. So, if you go to the
classroom here, scroll down. Uh the
prompt that we use is in this section,
right? So, we have a full section on
like how we create articles and rank
them using AICO. and they're the exact
same instructions and the prompt which
you can see down here. Um you can just
grab that in the description for using
inside the articles that we rank as
well. So if you want to rank those
articles, we use that prompt from that
section and then we use that to generate
articles and and get them ranking
directly inside openclaw. And then you
can see an example of how it works here.
So it's a pretty simple process. You
give the login details to WordPress um
to open claw. Then once you've done
that, you're going to give it a prompt
that helps it create content. And then
finally from that, what you want to do
is just give it a keyword so that it can
start ranking it, right? Um, and that's
basically how it works step by step. And
then you can see here our results with
SEO here. So these are some of the
keywords that we're ranking for like
mobile alarm, anti-gravity, etc. Like
stuff that that is trending right now.
We typically go for trending keywords.
The way that we decide on those keywords
we want to rank for is we use HF's
keyword explorer. So if I go to HFS over
here and you can do this inside Google
autocomplete. You don't have to use HFS.
I just like to use HFS data. So we can
go inside here we can select for example
the United States inside the country and
then we can just type in for example
let's say we want to rank for articles
about openclaw. Well we can find a bunch
of easy keywords and obviously openclaw
itself pretty hard to rank for. You
don't want to go for that. What you want
to do is instead just find some easy
keywords like you can see here. So these
are low difficulty keywords that you can
easily rank for. Right? So for example,
openclaw installation guide. Pretty easy
to rank for. I could probably get open
claw to create an article around that.
Um publish it to WordPress. Use the
prompt that I've given it and then it
can rank it. Right? And that's basically
what we're doing to rank articles like
you can see right here. Right? So it's a
pretty simple repeatable process. Um it
that content is still ranking directly
inside Google as well. Um, obviously
when we rank for keywords like that, it
generates traffic to our website, which
is awesome and it's all easy to
automate. The other crazy thing here as
well is that you can actually you you
can actually uh create this across
multiple platforms as well, right? So
for us, for example, we have multiple
websites, we have multiple platforms. We
don't just rely on one single platform
to rank. like we'll create articles on X
on Reddit uh all sorts of different
places because it's so easy to create
the content and automate it and then
publish it with something like open claw
and that's basically how the process
works right
we've actually got a full breakdown as
you can see inside the a profit
boardroom so step number one you're
going to connect open claw to your
website step number two you find a
keyword step number three you're going
to tell claw to write the article and
then step number four you're going to
schedule it to to run automatically each
day because obviously you can schedule
tasks with open claw. So you can say
like create one article a day on how to
use it and that sort of thing. We also
have a full six-hour course on how to
use openclaw inside the AR profitable
boardroom. This is basically my AI
community with 2,500 members as you can
see that shows you how to scale, save
time, and grow with AI automation. So
inside the community, you can ask
questions, you can get help, you can get
support whenever you need it. There's
always people online because there's so
many people inside the group. We have a
daily accountability group so that you
can stay 100% focused. Additionally,
what I also do is I research these tools
for like 60 hours a week and then I
condense it down into a weekly update
that you can just read inside this
section here so you can save time and
avoid overwhelm. Also, if you're
wondering, okay, like are people getting
results with this? How does it work? You
know, what what are people's experiences
with this? We've actually got 133 pages
of testimonials from people getting
great results with this. So you can see
all the testimonials of people just
getting awesome results with our school
communities, which is great. And you can
see examples of each of these uh on
screen right now. So it's it's awesome.
I mean, it's pretty much an infinite
scroll of people and their wins and and
what they're achieving through the
school groups. So I'm super happy with
that. And also inside the calendar, you
get four weekly coaching calls. You can
jump on live video calls, ask questions,
share your screen, get help, get support
whenever you need to. You can meet
people in your local area via the map,
which is great. It's kind of like a
network that connects you with loads of
people across the world. And then also
inside the classroom, you get all of my
best training. So, for example, if you
want to go from beginner to expert with
AI automation, learn how to build your
first AI agent in 5 minutes, you can
check that section out right here. If
you want to, for example, learn how I
automate X, newsletters, shorts,
Instagram, how I create avatar videos,
then we've got the full processes broken
down inside this section. If you want to
get the daily updates and all the AI SEO
training from today, including an extra
video tutorial, you can check that out
right here along with a full 6-hour
course on OpenCL and also another 3-hour
course over there. Um, we're also
updating this daily. So, you can see
we're just adding new trainings every
single day on how to use this stuff, how
to um implement it. We've tested out
alternatives like Clorex, uh, Copore. We
show you how to run free local APIs like
for example Lama with Quent 3.5 so that
you can actually connect this to um Open
Claw and get it running for free as you
can see right here. So every single day
we're just updating this with new
guides, new information, new video
tutorials that help you grow based on
what I think is most useful for you. Um
you can also learn how to get more
agency clients with the agency course.
You can watch your coaching calls back
and you can watch them back if you want
to as well. You can learn how to rank
number one with the AI SEO automation
section. We also have a section on how
to grow your YouTube channel with AI
based on what's working for me as well.
So that's all inside the AI profit
boredom link in the comments description
or just go to the aiprofitbedom.com.
Let's see what we got inside the
questions. So Doberman says, "Hello,
Bonour from France. Very cool your tips,
man. Thanks for all your videos. Happy
to help. Thank you very much, sir." Uh
Jason Fist says um install desktop claw
through Gemini. Uh I would recommend
using clawed code if people are watching
this and not sure what we're talking
about. So there's a desktop app for
openclaw that I covered yesterday in
this video tutorial. So you can see in
this section here we have a full video
tutorial and guide on how to use Clorex
which is a desktop app for open claw
kind of like claw codework but for open
claw directly. Um [snorts]
and that's that's basically it for the
videos
and the questions inside the comments.
Open claw and lobster board is insane.
So open core just got a superpower
upgrade and when you combine it with
lobster board it becomes something
completely different. So lobster board
is a free tool that gives you one single
screen showing everything and you can
host this locally for free. Here's an
example of what it looks like. So you
can add all these different widgets for
your open claw and basically this is a
free tool where you can check for
example your AI agents activity how many
tokens it's used the tasks website
traffic service stats all live all in
real time all in one place and most
people using openclaw have no idea what
that agent is actually doing this fixes
it completely and we're setting up the
whole thing together today I'll show you
how to build it from scratch right now
if you're running openclaw and you don't
have this set up then potentially you
don't really know or understand what
your agent's working on whether it's
doing things and you have no easy way of
seeing it all at once. Lobster board
basically changes that and it's a free
way to set this up as you can see right
here. Um so we're going to just have a
look at this. We'll look at how to build
dashboards together live. There's 50
widgets. Um you don't need to code. You
can get it set up in a couple of minutes
and by the end of this video you'll have
a beautiful live command center showing
you exactly what your AI is doing at all
times. So let's build it right now. So
this is lobster board and basically I've
already got it installed inside
openclaw. Let me show you an example of
how that worked. Right. So we literally
said can you install this? Gave it a
link to the GitHub for lobster board and
then once we did that we actually got
this installed. Now this is basically a
self-hosted drag and drop dashboard
builder. So you can kind of build your
own sort of mission control like you see
here with system log the schedule tasks
what you're working on today the
calendar everything connected to
openclaw but in a more visual way
because if you for example just use the
chat like you can see right here there's
not that much to organize right it's
just like it's a little bit messy um you
can go through the sections on the left
hand side here but it's not really like
a mission control dashboard this is
essentially what you're building inside
Lobster board so it took took a couple
of minutes to install that and we
literally said, "Can you install this?"
Then it thought for a few minutes and
then said, "Sure, lobster board is up
and running here." And then if we go to
that link, you can see an example. If we
edit out the layout, you can then edit
this how you want to. Now, you can
switch between five different styles as
you can see. So, you can switch between
all these different cool styles of the
way it's laid out. So, you get a lot of
um customization. Then, you can also
switch between the zoom and how much you
want to zoom in and that sort of thing.
So, we're just going to leave that on
default. You can change the canvas size.
So this is the canvas for your dashboard
that you can sort of build out. And then
there's a bunch of other stuff cool here
that you can for example like check out
templates, you can export templates, you
can clear the whole screen as well. So
we can actually clear all the widgets
off the screen there. And we can preview
that as well and then save it once it's
done. Right. So if we have a look on the
left hand side, we've got for example
like we can add a little countdown here.
We can scroll down. We can add like
details about our system like the CPU,
the dis usage etc. Network speed which
is pretty useful. Um you can add docker
if you're running open claw through
through docker as well which is easy.
And then if you just click on something
you want to delete it you can just click
on delete inside your keyboard and it
will delete that directly there. All
right. There's other interesting stuff
as well. So you can add like a sleep
score. So I get I guess you can connect
that to like an ring or something like
that which is pretty interesting. And
then over here we have the open claw
release calendar. So you can actually
check for new releases and these are
like specific to open claw right. So on
the left hand side you'll see that
you've got like system dashboards, you
got the basics. So this is just like
generic info but the most important
thing that probably most people would
use here is the open claw um linked
widgets. Right? So you can add like
chron jobs um system, you can add the
release details, you can add the
activity list, etc. All right. as you
can see. And then you can resize these
as well. So, we can move them around or
we can resize them in the bottom left
like you can see. Um, but it's a really
easy way to just build out like an
awesome missing control, right? It's
kind of like drag and drop. No messing
around. Super simple.
Open Claw can set it all up in a couple
of minutes. And it's completely free to
set up as well, right? Look at that.
Boom. Um, what else can we do here? We
can add like a to-do list. So, we can
edit a to-do list, which is pretty nice
as well. And
you can change the settings on the right
hand side. So you can say, okay, here's
a widget type, title, position, um
here's how often it should refresh. And
then here's the content um adjustable
things as well. If you want to delete
anything, you can just click on it and
then click delete widget over here. And
then you can add like even like the
GitHub stats. Um you can add all sorts
of crazy stuff. A quote of the day,
which is pretty nice. Content. Um, so
you can actually iframe embed a website
on here or you can add a new image and
that sort of thing. Um, you can add like
quick links if you just want to quickly
link out from your dashboard from
anywhere. And that's basically how it
works, right? Then once you've done
that, you can click on save. Then once
you've done that, you can click on
preview and this is what your dashboard
looks like. Right? So for example here,
if we actually go back to open call
control and we click on that link, we've
got the dashboard that we literally just
set up over here. Right? Super simple
and easy, very intuitive to use. Um, you
can customize it as much you want and it
gives you a ton of different widgets as
you can see here. Obviously, it's not
like I've not made it look super
beautiful because I'm just doing this on
a live stream right now and I'm doing it
live in front of you guys. But how cool
is that? Like you can it's even linked
directly to um everything automatically.
So, for example, here it's automatically
taken the information from OpenClaw.
It's got the information on the latest
release of open claw, how much disc
space this is taking up, how much system
memory is taken up as well and then the
system log as well. All right, and
whether open claw is actually up to
date. So you can just get all the key
information about open claw and just
manage it in one single place. And I
think this is the way that opens go in
is like you know you can have different
templates, you can have like mission
control and just easier ways to
orchestrate and organize open core. I
think that's that's the way that most
people want to be uh running this stuff.
Let's have a look what we got on the
questions.
Honestly, love this. Thank you very
much, sir.
What do you think is the best workflow
for building complex AI mobile apps? Uh,
the one that I've seen that's the best
is Rock. Rock is amazing for creating
apps and it makes it super simple to get
them published as well. So, I'd
recommend that instead. What else we got
here? Steven says, "Would you recommend
Perplexi Computer or Open Claw for
updating blogs?" For updating blogs, I
would recommend um using Open Claw
instead. That's actually proven for me.
Plexi Computer is great for like just
going off and doing tasks autonomously,
but it doesn't link to other things that
well so far. I think they're actually
updating. I saw it this morning where
they're going to add an update where it
links it to skills, but currently that
is not set up. Do you actually run
openclaw agents? Yes, as of shown today.
So, we've already shown for example an
example workflow where I was ranking um
with the content the SEO content that
OpenClaw created. So, it's pretty
simple. What skills would you recommend
for openclaw?
And so if you go to the classroom inside
the AI profitable board link in the
comments description and then just go to
the skills update. So we've we've got a
bunch of ideas on skills and that sort
of thing. I also show you like how to be
careful with this stuff because if
you're installing anything related to
open quil you always want to be checking
okay um what the skill MD files saying
etc. Uh is it secure and I have a lot of
training on all of that inside there.
What's the desktop? Is it free? Yes, you
can use um what is it now? We've got a
full training on it inside this section,
right? It's Clorex. That's the one I
checked out yesterday. So, this is a
desktop app for Open Claw.
Cory says, I have my OpenClaw running on
a VM in OVH cloud. How can I actually
connect other services? So, you just
give it the API, right? So if you want
to connect it to 11 labs for example for
generating voice um outputs then you
would just get an API for 11 labs and
give it to open claw and say like save
this as a skill.
How can I get open claw to send me
reminders through discord. So you would
connect it to discord. We've got lots of
training on that inside the course here.
Right. And once you've connected it to
discord in fact let me show you
something even better. So inside this
section, we have a full section on
Discord parallel agents and how to set
those up. Once you've connected it to
Discord, you can actually say, okay,
schedule this task and give me reminders
like every 5 hours, for example, inside
Discord. So it's pretty simple. What do
I tell OpenCloud to install this
dashboard? So to install the dashboard,
all you do is you say, can you install
this? And then you paste in the GitHub
link, which you can see from lobster
board right here.
And uh Sebastian says, "Have you seen
the guy that made an iOS um app
factory?" No, but that's pretty cool. I
like the idea of that. That's awesome.
Um there's so many cool people doing so
many cool things with open claw. I think
that's the fantastic thing about it
being open source.
So that is basically how to use Lobster
board. That's that's how it works, etc.
I've shown you how to install it, shown
you how to set it up, how to use it, and
how it works in real time. Um, it's
really cool. It's a really powerful
tool. If you want to get a full guide on
how to use it, all the best ways to use
it, etc., you get that inside the AR
profit boarding along with all of my
best trainings on OpenClaw. So, you can
see, for example, here we give you a
six-hour course on how to use OpenClaw.
Here we have another three-hour course
on how to use it with all the best use
cases and the step-by-step guide. We
update this daily. So we add new
trainings every single day on openclaw
and all the new updates that come out
just to help you as much as we can. So
for example recently we compared all the
alternatives. We show you how to run
open claw for free with o lama and we
even for example show how to set up
mission control with openclaw to build
like awesome dashboards automatically.
So you don't even need to drag and drop
this stuff. So you can get that all
inside the arprofit boarding link in the
comments description or just go to the
arprofitboard.com.
This is my AI automation community that
helps you save time, scale, and grow
with AI automation. Now, inside the
community, you can ask questions, get
help, get support whenever you need to.
We also have a daily accountability
group so that you can stay focused and
avoid information overwhelm. And
additionally, you can see that what I do
is I condense my 60 hours of research
each week on AI tools and I show you
what's interesting, what's useful, and
what you can safely ignore so that you
save time, right? It's just like here's
the top three most useful things that
came out this week. Here's everything
else you can safely ignore.
Additionally, you can see here that for
the AR profit boarding, we actually have
over 133 pages of testimonials from
happy people inside our school
community. So, you can see lots of
people getting wins. It's pretty much a
infinite scroll at this point and you
can see some of the awesome stuff and uh
how people are winning with this stuff.
So, that's great to see too. Also,
inside the calendar, you can get four
weekly coaching calls. So you can get
weekly coaching calls and jump on live
calls and get help and support in real
time. Inside the map, you can connect
with local community members. What this
means essentially, it's like a
networking group where you can meet cool
people in your area and you can connect
with them locally, which is great. Just
zoom in on the area. Inside the
classroom, you can get access to all of
my best training. So you can go from
beginner to expert with AI automation
and learn how to build your first AI
agent in under five minutes.
Additionally, you'll get all my best
playbooks. So for example, you can learn
how to automate AI avatar videos,
shorts, Instagram, newsletters, Twitter,
etc. We have all of my best automations
inside the classroom. And then
additionally, you can see that we update
daily with new interesting guides inside
the SAP update section. So I just look
at everything that comes out. I'm like,
right, boom. Here's the most interesting
stuff for you right now. Uh Stephan
Thomasson says, "You're amazing. Thank
you, Julian. Happy to help and I'm glad
that it helps." So that's it. Thanks for
watching. Appreciate it. Hope to get
hope to see you inside the AI profit
boardroom link in the comments
description or just go to the aiprofit
boardroom.com
open claw use cases. So, I just built a
website with over 500 openclaw use
cases, and today I'm going to show you
exactly how to use it. This is organized
by category. It also shows you, for
example, who's using it, how to get
access to it. The prompt you can just
copy and paste to start automating with
this task. And you can click between or
search inside this section to get over
500 use cases across 14 different
categories uh with 500 different copy
and paste prompts. And all of these have
proven case studies and links to example
case studies as you can see right here.
So if you're looking for real ways to
use OpenClaw, this is one of the best
ways to do it. Most people set up
OpenClaw and then just kind of stare at
it. They have no idea what to do with it
and that ends today. This website's
basically a cheat code because you have
over 500 real things you can make open
claw do for you right now. Not someday
today. Plus all the copy and pasteable
prompts to use it too with links to
example case studies for each use case.
So we're talking, for example, building
tools, running tasks, automating your
entire workflow, all without writing a
single line of code. And the crazy part
is most people of OpenClaw have no idea
any of this is even possible. And that's
exactly why we built this. So today I'm
going to talk you through the whole
setup, show you how to find the right
use cases for you, and I can show you
how we can test some of them live
together. So by the end of this video,
you're going to know exactly how to make
OpenClaw 100 times more powerful, right?
So if we have a look at open claw and
this setup right here basically what you
can see is that we've split this into
categories. So we've researched all of
the use cases. So for example, if we
have a look at this um you can see that
we've actually for example taken the
morning brief example use case which is
from this website right um which is
looking at how people are using open
claw and then what we've done is we've
created a prompt where you can just
implement that yourself right so if you
want to just uh steal this example you
can just copy and paste a prompt then
you can go over to open claw and use
this example case study um right here.
So, we can just paste our prompt right
here. And we can say, okay, every day I
see it 7:00 a.m. Uh, send me a morning
brief with unread email summary, today's
calendar, weather, and my top three
tasks. Right? And then if I paste in
that example prompt into openclaw, it's
going to implement it right now. Right?
Um, and that's basically how all of this
works. So, it's a really simple setup.
It's super easy to use and basically you
can just check out whatever you want. So
for example here we could for example in
inbox um and declutter our emails right
we could turn our meeting notes to
action items. All of these prompts are
examples of real ways people are
actually using this. So we even for
example said u maintain my grocery list
when I say add um x add it group items
by produce um and whenever I ask and
give me the list whenever I need it
right all sorts of stuff. Now if we go
to for example like content creation we
can say okay generate 20 YouTube video
ideas for niche channel include and then
it would just generate ideas for my
channel right here and again we have
links to the actual case studies of
people using this stuff right so for
example here I actually linked to
Matthew Burman's article where he talks
about how to use this sort of stuff and
[snorts]
if you need like more information on
that particular topic or if you want to
just dive deeper into it right so it's
[snorts] a pretty amazing tool
Basically, the way that I built it, just
to be 100% transparent with you, is I
went into Claude and just said like,
"Give me 500 use cases of how people can
use AI and and what it works." Um, let
me try and find the original chat here.
Yeah. So,
This is basically how we built it like
just so you know how to build your own
version if you wanted to.
Um, so we said like find me 500 use
cases for openclaw and then a lot of the
links came back super generic like the
links weren't correct for most of them.
And then from there we gave it more
ideas, more briefing on how to do it.
Added a CTA to our community on top of
it. And then um also created a full
step-by-step guide on on what Open Claw
is and that sort of thing, right? And
then once you've done that and once
you've generated a website like you can
see right here with the 500 use cases um
you can just click on share artifacts
and that's how you can create an awesome
website like this for whatever tool you
want to learn about. So if you want to
get the full details on that we've
actually got it for free this if you
want to get access to this website it's
completely free inside the AI success
lab link in the comments description. So
just go to the classroom and then you
would go to this section here, the March
2026 version and you can just get access
right there, right? And you click on
that link and it takes you directly to
the website where you can just search
through and use it however you want to.
So if you're wondering, okay, what are
the best skills, the best use cases, how
it works, etc. It's all right here for
you for free.
So that's basically it for me. Thanks
very much for watching today.
Um that is 500 use cases on how OpenAI
works. If we have a look at the main use
cases here. So you got like productivity
and admin, developer and coding, content
creation, research and learning. Uh
marketing and SEO is a big big one. So
I'd recommend checking out that. That's
probably one of the most useful
sections. Uh communication messaging,
you got smart home and personal life.
This is quite interesting as well cuz
like a lot of people are using this for
their personal life too, not just for
like business related stuff. And you can
see some examples of prompts um and how
people are using this with uh links to
case studies and everything else. We've
also got stuff for example for like
community and social data and analytics
automation integration like you can
actually this is quite interesting. So
for example, if you want to create sub
agents, we have a prompt for it right
here with examples of how it works. And
you can see here the prompt is like root
task to specialized agents, coding tasks
to whatever. And you can separate your
open claw into different agents
depending on the work um required. So
that's all inside here with advanced
prompts and and copy and pasteful use
cases as you can see. So thanks very
much for watching. Appreciate it. Um if
you haven't already, feel free to check
out the AI profit boardroom. This is my
AI automation community where we really
deep dive on stuff like openclaw uh link
in the comments description or just go
to the AI profitab.com. This really
focus on helping you save time at scale
with AI automation. So for example, we
have a daily accountability group where
you can post your goals, stay
accountable, um and make sure you avoid
information overload plus see what other
people are working on which is great. We
have a weekly update post. So each week
I condense my 60 hours of re research
into what's good and what you can safely
ignore to save you time. You can post
questions inside the community, get help
and support whenever you need to. And
then also inside the calendar here, you
can jump on weekly video calls, get help
and support in real time. Um these are
Zoom meetings where you can actually
meet the community as well. Inside the
map, you can actually zoom in on your
local area and meet cool people in your
area which is awesome. And then inside
the classroom, you can get all of my
best training. So, for example, you can
go from beginner to expert with AI
automation and learn how to build your
first AI agent in under five minutes.
Additionally, inside the classroom, you
can get my best playbooks on, for
example, how to automate X, newsletters,
shorts, AI avatar videos, and everything
else.
Additionally,
you can get my daily updates. So inside
this section we update this with all the
new updates. So recently for example
today we created a new training on open
AI uh openclaw AI SEO lobster board 500
open core use cases. Um you can see
we've already covered a video on chat
GBT 5.3 instant and Gemini 3.1
flashlight. These came out today and we
just cover them as soon as we can with a
video tutorial and a step-by-step guide
so you can implement and learn how to
use this stuff yourself. And we do that
every single day, right? Um, also inside
the classroom here, you can learn how to
get more clients with the agency course.
You can watch about the coaching calls
over here. You can connect with me
personally. So, you can actually direct
message me personally inside here. And
then you can learn how to rank inside
Google and AI search engines with this
section and how to grow a YouTube
channel with AI based on what's working
for me. So, that's all inside the AI
profit boardroom. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you on the next one.
Cheers. Bye-bye.
Um, Corey says, "Do you cover open
source models?" Yeah, absolutely. So if
you go inside the classroom here, uh we
actually just covered the recent release
of Quen 3.5 via O Lama and also Alama
and PI which is a free local AI coding
agent, right? So if you want to learn
about open source models, we have tons
of training on Olama and these all come
with videos and step-by-step guides. So
you can just type in Olama and we show
you for example how to set up like KimK
2.5 for free with open claw or for
example how to use GLM 4.7 flash for
free with open claw. So if you like open
source local models, we have tons of
training on that inside the AI profer
boardroom as well. Thanks for watching.
Appreciate it. See you on the next one.
Cheers. Bye-bye.